can we talk about what only fans does to
society because you know we were talking
about this downstairs a couple days ago
it's basically all of these young women
are deciding that they want to be
prostitutes it's just like it's it's
like a digital version of it but it's
basically the same thing men can
subscribe to pay you money in exchange
for this Behavior there was this uh clip
that's going viral right now I think
clown World reposted it from the
whatever podcast where a woman says that
she was hooking up with a guy just to
break his heart
right yeah and then and then you know
the dude from whatever is like she says
her hobby is the humble men and he's
like and someone says you're a stripper
yeah he says it yeah and then she's like
yeah but I take their money and it's
like no listen I feel like a lot of what
we're talking about what you're
describing with um dudes who have like
addictions addictions and you mentioning
like women getting run through whatever
and then only fans and stripping is that
people are doing things that are
genuinely detrimental across the board
throughout the study not just related to
dating yeah and there are people who
don't want to feel bad about it because
misery loves company so they tell
everybody what you're doing is totally
fine keep doing it even though it's
really bad and the obvious example the
the actual visible example is morbid
obesity like we know that if you are
eating and gorging yourself you will die
sooner and we don't want that we want
you to live a long healthy life but the
people who enjoy eating hot fudge
sundaes all day every day don't want to
stop they're addicted so instead of
accepting and admitting themselves they
have a problem they seek out validation
from other people who are addicted
creating a society of people who are
engaging in extremely detrimental
behaviors across the board which brings
you back to only fans I I've met women
who have said
they've tried it and they gave up
because they weren't making money and
now they have a bunch of online it's
everywhere they were like people people
stole the videos people recorded the
videos people did a whole bunch of stuff
and they made like 17 and that was it
and that there you are you're you're a
prostitute forever never never you can
never change it yeah I mean the I can't
remember what the average amount of
money is for a woman that goes on only
fans but it's not a lot I thought it was
like 20 bucks or something yeah it's not
I wish I don't remember what it is but I
remember thinking like wow that's such a
low payout but it's also why is that any
amount is enough for someone to do that
in this culture like but I I think
Sheamus women and men are very very
different yeah and it is sad but
consider there's tons of stories of
women quitting their jobs to become
prostitutes or like marrying into money
I mean it's basically similar kind of
thing if you don't love the guy sure
gold digging but it's it's still
different to marry someone like to enter
into a binding contract granted now with
no fault divorce it is kind of
meaningless it used to be like you got
married you were there till the dude
died and then okay Al Pacino's like 90
he's got a 28 9 year old wife and she's
pregnant yep man the wild oh you know in
defense of uh only fans I think it was
evilovia was talking about this because
she did it uh you porn and the porn
industry girls
you can't guarantee that they're not 18
uh in the porn industry it's very
difficult to vet the process so there's
a lot of child porn that gets through in
that system whereas on only fans it's
vetted a hundred percent so you know
everything on there is legal and above
board I'm not I'm not opposed to porn
generally like I'm fairly libertarian
people can do their thing my issue is
there is a social Trend among many women
there's like a story of like a nurse
like I was a nurse making 50 000 year
and I quit now I make 200 doing porn
like
is is this a good thing I I don't think
it is like I don't know maybe maybe I I
should start reading some more books by
sex positive feminists no that is the
last thing that you should do that
I think women lie too about how much
they make because I went on the whatever
podcast and there was like I don't know
four or five girls that said they made
over 20k a month and I ran the numbers
and it was like less than 2 000 people
or 3 000 people in the U.S make the
number of like make the money they're
saying they make them like what are the
odds they're all on one show I think
there's some incentive to lie about it
oh absolutely well yeah well that's also
a fair point and it's a sad thing
because because a person might be
embarrassed how embarrassing would that
be oh my gosh you put your body on the
internet and you can get 10 buyers
this is this is the reality of it yeah
so so there are a few there are people a
few people I know I know one woman who
did uh cam girl stuff and she literally
thought that she would be making she see
these stories the here's the crazy thing
these stories encourage more women to do
it and it never works so you get these
women to go on these shows and say I'm
making 20K a month and they're not and
then I have a friend who's like I'm
gonna try doing it and I'm like yeah you
probably shouldn't do that it's not
going to work out and then when what did
she say said all it was was people
sending messages saying please post for
free please post for free I want a free
sample and then she made like 17 and was
like this is this is nuts like there's
no money here but now everything's out
there well ins oh go ahead well and the
girl on the show I looked at her only
fans I mean not like that you know I
just wanted to see how many subscribers
she had and there was like no premium
content so I was like how where are you
making she said she made 50k a month so
I'm like it's not true well no I was
thinking it could be like prostitution
oh that was my thought like over it's I
think I think only thing is
prostitutions yes well yeah but I was
thinking like if they don't make it
through there maybe they go through yeah
well it's it's a very sad thing because
you could also imagine someone being
embarrassed about that not admitting
there not making any money and then what
they're saying to make themselves sound
impressive convinces more young women to
do the same thing that they're doing so
you know maybe they're making fifty
dollars
like again no amount makes that worth it
but that is um that is really sad well I
got good news though with AI technology
all of this industry will be wiped out
wiped out clean all these women there
will not be women who are making a
living doing this anymore it's going to
be a bunch of dudes and they're going to
be going to you know
porn.ai or whatever I don't even know
that exists and they're going to be like
render me a video of like two guys in a
check and then it's gonna render the
video and they're gonna upload it and
charge five bucks for it but then what's
gonna happen is every person in the
world will just buy a subscription to
the porn AI bot and just tell it
whatever they want yeah and so then
women will be like these women who are
doing it now are going to be like I
can't make any money doing it anymore
dude porn has already caused so many
problems for society AI porn is just
going to be unbearable dude people are
going to go insane you'll be able to
change it in real time you'll be
watching be like that
I have a question do you think with the
growing like rise of sexless men that
porn is actually like helpful to society
because they're not then aggressive
maybe that typically happens I think
like wasn't that a conspiracy theory and
also with with do you think it keeps
together sexless marriages
uh so if so I would say that if it's a
crutch to lean on it actually causes far
more problems than it solves uh I think
that like the Warped understanding of
sex that we have in the first place that
allows for for porn to be uh not only
legal but so prolific is the same
corrupt set of sexual morals that allows
for things like no fault divorce and for
these sexless marriages to happen so I
think it's all one uh part of the same
corrupt infrastructure and we just have
to do away with all of it you know you
know I think I think women care
substantially more about what other
women think of them oh yeah and so
that's a big component of all all of
this when it comes to marriages when it
comes to people who are upset there you
you and maybe it's just because of of
what I see in TVs and movie and what I
hear from other people which are who are
influenced by teams and movie but it
seems so often there's many stories of
women who are like in a relationship
with the husband and then they're
talking to their other woman friend and
they say here's the thing my husband and
they go oh no that's so bad and they're
like oh no and now I feel bad about it
you're absolutely right like I've talked
to so many and that's why like the Trad
cons will come in and be like oh just
find the right girl she won't do any of
like the divorce stuff they won't be in
a sexless marriage just find the right
girl but the thing is like women are so
easily influenced like I'll have guys
for the divorce documentary they'll have
a girl she had like all the typical like
checkpot like boxes checked that you
would want in a wife and then like she
gets in the wrong group of friends and
then she just divorces her husband takes
the kids takes half and just ruins this
man's life well divorce is contagious
right yeah we know that if you have a
friend who's divorced you're you're more
likely to get divorced I would say that
it's really important look it in our
modern time we have this very like
atomized vision of what family should be
you know you just have two people living
in a house together with their children
no extended family nearby and you're
also not part of a community that has
the same values as you I would say uh if
somebody wants to live a traditional
life it's not enough to find one other
traditional person right uh you you
probably want to be surrounded by people
in a community that is more traditional
where it would be an absolute Scandal if
you end up well I just I think that's
going to be harder and harder with media
absolutely and so but the thing is I
just think things won't really change
until they change the laws that's my
personal opinion as many many of you
know I was just banned on Tick Tock and
we are demonetized on a daily basis on
this platform if you want to help please
consider sending a super thanks below
every donation helps and it helps make
what we do possible